in the world of sea you can be the queen
you can be a leader of a tribe you can
be a warrior each individual is treated
as an equal in our show
i got to do something as an actor that
i've never done before
i've worked so hard to play character
like this it was just incredible to work
with joe he's a producer he's blind and
he's there to further the development of
the characters in the best way possible
here's joe stretcher to give you some
more advice it's beautiful to have
someone like joe and help me through it
we wanted to make sure we were
representing our community positively
so we looked at the littlest behaviors
and how characters who are blind move in
the world
i went in completely open-minded and joe
will come up and give me his notes and
i'll say i just never even thought about
it that way we try to do everything we
can to make sure that this feels
authentic for the blind community and
joe is key in that
we have numerous actors who are blind or
low vision and we want to make sure that
their needs are met when they come to
work this is amazing it's just such an
experience i was treated just with the
utmost care and respect everyone has
such a good relationship and here
everyone's like you're an actor you're
with us we fight for our families we
fight for our freedom
we try to make sure that our characters
who are blind aren't using non-verbal
communication you know like even nodding
the head yes or shaking the head no
we're gonna use our ears to listen right
we're not looking at him speak we're
listening to him speak right physical
gestures mean very little in this world
if you're moving your hands it should be
purposeful around grabbing something
touching something
making a sound with your hands
they've done such a great job in the way
they portray blindness or visual
impairments joe started to teach me
about echolocation
you make sound
and then find out the size of a room
beautiful room where people are i had no
idea there was something that people
could do
everything is conceptually designed to
be authentic to what a world would be
like if most of the world didn't have
sight
the things we build are beautiful but
there's also a lot of logic built into
it
like putting tap lines down the middle
of the road get their directions so they
find a path the plates had individual
little grooves around the edge of the
charger so that the staff could actually
figure out where the table setting is in
the wedding the ribbons had bells on
them so that everyone could hear the
reaction
[Music]
with wardrobe forces you to use your
other senses for fabrics for touch it's
the texture and then also does it make
sound
[Music]
i was really proud of everyone how hard
everyone trained
we work with every performer to help
bring them in the world to see
and then this team really creates
something beautiful
[Music]
you